good morning believe nation today's
message is progress equals happiness
over to you Tony Robbins things getting
things is not gonna make you happy
that's good news in a tough economy it's
a good reminder you know doesn't matter
what you get doesn't matter whether it
be money or opportunity all those things
might excite you for the moment you know
even a relationship as magnificent it
may be might be exciting for a while but
if you don't keep growing that
relationship isn't gonna stay exciting
so the secret to real happiness is
progress progress equals happiness and
if we can make progress on a regular
basis we feel alive and that's why at
the beginning of the year we get this
thing like okay I can have this fresh
start I could really do with my soul
desires I could expand I could grow I
can improve I could change or maybe
better than change I could progress see
think about that progress is an
aliveness to it doesn't it you don't
have to work at changing people say all
the time that allow I'm working on
changing don't worry about it you have
to work on changing changes automatic
your body's gonna change whether you
want it or not as the years go by you no
matter how hard you work there's gonna
be some changes going on there and the
economy is gonna change no matter what
you want it to do the weather is gonna
change relationships are gonna change
everything in life is always changing
look after work on change change is
automatic but progress is not this is an
awesome message because I think a lot of
people are too wrapped up into things
and to money they think that find that
new car buying that new toy you know
having that extra money will make them
happy where it's not where it's really
much more about you learning and
becoming a better person if you feel
like you're growing then you're much
more likely to be a happy person I think
back to a failed startup that I had a
number of years ago where we weren't
making money and we weren't doing well
and through it all somehow I was still
happy and a year into it when I my
business partner said Evan I'm not happy
I don't feel like I'm learning and
growing and I look at you and you've
learned all these things you need to
getting better
these new skills and you become a better
person through this and I feel like I
haven't grown at all and that was the
difference right it wasn't about how
much money we're making it wasn't know
how many customs we brought on it was
that I felt like I was growing and
building myself up and learning new
skills and he felt like he wasn't and so
I was happy and he wasn't so if you're
looking at your own life right now and
you're thinking that you're not happy I
really challenge you to look at are you
growing enough are you doing anything
different are you learning something new
in your business or in your personal
life if you're doing the same thing the
same routine over and over and over and
over and over again it's going to slowly
eat you alive and the key to breaking
free is to start doing things where you
can challenge yourself and see some
progress again so my question of the day
for you guys today is I want to know in
the past year where have you seen the
most progression as a human being for
yourself where have you grown the most
I'm really curious to find out leave it
in the comments below thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso